if someone recognizes you from you too
this is this is an education this is a
teachable moment if Sean recognizes you
from YouTube there's a ninety-nine
percent chance that they'll sleep with
you statistically true hello bug buddies
so today we're going to talk about
purpose in life here's something to keep
in mind that no matter what you do
you're not going to fail when I started
it was like first a blog that I would
just write stuff and it was like on
xanga this is like millions of years ago
and it needed a tagline and so what came
to mind was a little Davey wavey goes a
long way my parents used to call me
Davey wavey when I was little and then
when people started watching my videos
and then reading my blog they just
started calling me Davey wavey because
of that tagline and I was like oh that's
pretty cool because it's like super
googleable and it's easy to remember
[ __ ] rhymes like it's it's there's a lot
of David's in the world but there's only
there's only one day if you way to be so
it was kind of perfect I just kind of
fell into it all the YouTube stuff it
feels like it just kind of fell into
place and some like magical way I'm not
saying that that God sent me to be the
guy youtuber but but he did there are
two funny things about the loophole
first the loophole holds 200 gallons of
MU which retails for approximately sixty
seven thousand dollars uh I swim in a
pool with sixty seven thousand dollars
worth of lube in it that was the
highlight of my career because pretty
much like after that you could only you
can only go downhill the reality of the
loop pool though is like the loop was
really cold and it was really heavy and
I kept like sliding back and I and I
kept thinking that I go back underwater
that like they're gonna try to like
reach and rescue me but I'm so lubed
that like they're just going to slide
off my arm and I'm gonna drown in this
pool of lube and I will be dead like
this is how I will die but in a way
that's like such a fitting in me
I did a series of like bucket list
things so like I jumped out of a plane
at the drag queen I climbed a volcano in
Hawaii I rode an elephant in Thailand
like i did a list of things i wanted to
cross off my bucket list and swimming
pool Lou was on that list and honestly I
thought it was probably the one thing
that was so like inaccessible because
lube is really freaking expensive and
takes one a pool of it I'm pretty sure
I'm like the only person world that has
done that this is our silicone based
lube oh my god the best experience was
and it was actually very sweet I was in
LA I was doing a meet up at like the
highland mall or there's some kind of
ball on Hollywood Boulevard and there
was a kid who was like 12 years old who
came in with his mom it was on Mother's
Day she drove him from Palm Desert into
into the city they get like stuck in the
hours traffic and we were going I was
with a friend of mine and after the
meetup we were going to go see the
Cirque du Soleil show in LA and like
they literally drove it on mother's day
just to say hi and they came in just the
very end of the meetup and I could say
hey and thank you and we ended up giving
them my the tickets to Cirque because it
was like mother's day and they could
like go celebrate and then we just got
more tickets but then we get to see them
like come in it was like really really
super cute whenever someone recognizes
me from YouTube it's always like the
immediate reaction is like I can only do
what I do because they watch my videos
so you feel this like immediate sense of
gratitude which then like oscillates
between like weirdness and gratitude
because I'm they're like oh like how's
your dog chipotle doing I'm like how do
you know my dog's name is chipotle oh
cuz she's been in videos so it's it's
it's weird because you're kind of just
making videos and putting them out there
and it's easy to forget that like
millions of people are that on the
receiving end of that but it's also
really cool and and I do get recognized
more with my shirt
the with the nipples out I do want to be
recognized for my nipples yeah that's
how I want to that's my legacy yeah
enjoy I can use my nipples as a can
opener I can hypnotize people with them
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel I think the biggest turn on turn
off for me because a guy that would be
like very judgmental so if you guys like
sweet and genuine and and very nice and
friendly like that that's great and if
he has a big dick that's just like icing
on the cake do you know I mean is that
too much to ask we could really like
sweet nice guy but I mean like a big
like you're out there tweet me at the
Davey wavey like this you know what you
like going like a roller coaster like
you need to be this tall to ride this
ride to ride this ride I want to find
out God cares I'm gay so I decided to
ask her for myself do you know what they
say Trust is like a mirror you can fix
it if it's broke but you can still see
the crack and that motherfucker's
reflection oh wait sorry wrong video yes
I could dig up till you hit go I don't
give a [ __ ] at your gay I was about
three years ago when I like made the
switch to do a full time almost three
years ago and I remember being so scared
to like give up my real job to do this
because there's like this perceived risk
and like you're jumping into the on know
like you're putting yourself out there
but in hindsight i think the real risk
would have been to keep working and like
and look past this amazing opportunity
that youtube had like handed me like
that would have been the real risk
because it's like I'm doing what I love
what I'm passionate about like driven by
that passion in a way that method it
like not that it's saving the world but
like some of my video like I think
there's a certain value in people seeing
an openly gay man except himself and
Beyond apologetic about who he is
there's a certain value in that and so
I'm doing what I love driven by my
passion
a way that helps other people and how
could you ever possibly fail doing that
you can't like you connect it's never
like I can't give a date when I knew you
were gay but I just I always well when
the Martha Stewart Living magazine would
come to the house and you're like five
six years old mom I your favorite
magazine is here let's sit down and look
at it together I said okay this is it
this is typically the cc0 Hawaii I came
out to myself I think in sixth grade and
that was when I realized that there were
like other gay people because when I was
in sixth grade we didn't have YouTube or
you know people making videos about anal
douching or whatever and Will and Grace
was not on TV and so I that's when I
learned that there was something called
being gay and and that's what I'm not
the only one there's other people like
this and then I came out to my parents
when I was 17 my friends like when I was
16 now I'm 29 and you still come out to
people like ever every time I like hold
a man's hand on the street that I'm
seeing but you're coming out to the
people that see you on the street do you
remember the day that I came out yes I
do Jamie join 90s 2001 use them on have
to talk to you and you were leaning up
against me and of you but I guess your
heart was like go real real fast I just
remember that I said oh my God he's got
something really serious to tell me I
couldn't get myself to say words I'm gay
when I came out to my parents my mom
sent me to a Catholic priest and he told
my mom that the only problem was that I
was too comfortable with being gay but I
mean if it took me if it took me 17
years become comfortable not to tell
them then I like realize that I could
also give them some time to become
comfort
with it and it took them a few years to
kind of get to where they need to be but
today like they treat the guys that I
see no different than they you know
would treat my sister's husband or
boyfriend what it's to them it's kind of
the same thing my mom thinks that that
if she watches one of my videos I will
know i have like installed some piece of
like software totally totally untrue I
hope she's not watching but I will show
them the ones that I think are
appropriate it's not all my videos about
penises like there's there's some that
are like PG 13 / like r / xxx but the
ones that are appropriate I show my
parents and and and I mean at the end of
the day like you would you want to hear
your son talking about like sex no
probably not um so it's like reading
your kids diary I think but she gets
upset she's like well millions of people
all over the world could watch your
videos but your own mother can't watch
it yes ipod buddies today we talked
about surviving being gay and catholic
may or may not know that I was raised
Catholic in that I also went to Catholic
High School Catholic University and I am
living I survived the experience and
today I'm going to tell you how to do it
too I mean for the first probably 22
years of my life I went to Catholic
school Catholic High School Catholic
College like I learned day in and day
out that I was going to hell because of
the people because me being gay because
of who I was attracted to and in a
society that though it is getting better
still treats you essentially as a
second-class citizen in a lot of
different places it's getting better but
that's still the reality people can get
fired you get kicked out of your house
whatever parents disowning children that
in the face of all that that you can
look yourself in the mirror and be like
you know what
Who I am and and I would not want to be
any different that I love the person
that I am that's a pretty big step to
take and it took me a while to to kind
of get there but I have and hopefully
when people watch my videos they feel
inspired to do the same hi grandma it's
David how are you it's something that
I've wanted to tell you for a while but
I wasn't really sure how you would react
so has a little nervous to tell you that
well hey grandma they call it being gay
now you don't have to say homosexual oh
it means a lot to me hear you say that
so thank you and and I love you okay oh
I'll call you again soon alright okay
alright I love you too all right okay
for me YouTube just gives you so much
freedom to like do what you want to do
without any one controlling that like I
think I could today decide I want to
make a video and edit it till it post it
tomorrow you know there's no one else
involved in that process so it's so
authentic and I think people really
respond to that if you go into TV or
film you lose up you lose you give up
some of that that freedom but then the
flip side you reach so much so many more
people so I don't know I i'm open to see
where things go and whatever
opportunities from across but I think
YouTube is kind of I don't know has a
special place in my heart what I'm doing
thanks for watching my interview for
more pictures and more great stuff make
sure you go to new media rockstars calm
and you can subscribe and if your dick
is as big as my arm make sure you
subscribe to my channel tweet me I love
you guys I'll talk to you soon he's up I
have a world tour coming up in September
it's 30 days and it's eight cities
around the world I'm going to film a
video in city so it's Montreal London's
comb I'm Copenhagen Amsterdam Singapore
Melbourne Sydney in each city i'm going
to film a video and do a meet up with
people that watch my videos they loaded
for where they want me to go so in
theory is like the eight most like
heavily concentrated DD maybe fan cities
so it's kind of like a way to say thank
you and to meet fans and to film some
great content because that's when you go
to these places there's always a really
cool stuff to find